this [ __ ] game it's impossible higher
or lower you have to guess which one of
the two is the most googled one come on
the solar system or Donkey Kong Country
I love Donkey Kong Country it's one of
my favorite games of all the time but
ain't no [ __ ] [ __ ] it's more googled
than the solar system I'm kind of losing
faith of humanity if that's the case
lower please Donkey Kong Country I love
your Donkey Kong dick what the [ __ ] did
I just say oh so he continues Donkey
Kong Country vs the Big Bang Theory oh
my [ __ ] god I swear to God if the Big
Bang Theory has more I will end myself
right [ __ ] now higher oh god I think
I just got some uncurable AIDS
alright The Big Bang Theory Jesus or a
German Shepherd are y'all playing along
German Shepherd gotta be lower
[ __ ] you German Shepherd Mark Zuckerberg
is higher I'm pretty good at this what
the [ __ ] man
Mark Zuckerberg buries Leo tolls with
that [ __ ] who the [ __ ] are you a Russian
writer he wrote more on peas lower come
on man give me a [ __ ] challenge house
of cards higher this is too easy man hit
but a pig lower Oh
what how
let's do this again play Allah oh [ __ ]
me did you have to use that [ __ ]
picture man the Vietnam War a
rhinoplasty I feel like that's something
that people want to research before they
do and I assume that that people
googling more than the Vietnam War holy
[ __ ] I was wrong all right Temple Run or
Christianity what is more popular
Christianity I think what no I think the
Grand Canyon
I think Angry Birds
I think twerking is not that popular
anymore I'm on a roll
whoo they don't do the same [ __ ] what
that [ __ ] just happened
I gotta get 10 we got it we gotta get 10
breasts
what the [ __ ] is very hip that's a very
specific search term but I'm gonna go
higher anyway ha hey we got 6 Justin
Bieber definitely higher zoo I like [ __ ]
wait I want purified to show up how many
searches is pit if I have Madden 16 has
to be more sorry Zoe
I am sorry but I think madam is more
popular than what what Zoe
what the hell you ruin it how could you
do this thanks now I got a restart
thanks thanks a lot thanks a lot Zoe
I searched most popular searches google
pewdiepie and the first thing that comes
up is pewdiepie as a fraud
hear me out I understand that I may seem
arrogant and angry he's saying I'm a
fraud because I don't get 32 million
views I'm on each one of my videos does
the guy know that I have over 8 billion
views in total No then [ __ ] [ __ ] off
then PewDiePie is the most popular
youtube star in the world by a question
mark
that's a nice article how about I call
myself a new sort and start being
passive-aggressive to everyone that
that'd be [ __ ] awesome so PewDiePie
was the most-searched back in 2014
probably when most people heard about me
for the first time what if we add this
[ __ ] ha Jack you can suck it all right
what if we add
oh my god this proves nothing this means
nothing [ __ ] you
Prada is more yeah dammit I can't get
ten I know you are
no Samsung user does not have autism
[ __ ] you for insinuating that Shin lower
seat
lower come on all right
iPhone you're back in the game iPhone
come on bro 9 bro 9 / 9 come on come on
come on oh god no that's easy Manchester
has to be higher mmm I'll do the jontron
Jeff Find My iPhone is more conspiracy
theories please be lower yes
air pollution lower all right we got 12
we got [ __ ] 12 all right guys it's a
really fun game I really enjoy it
recommend checking it out link in the
description leave a like if you enjoyed
this video if you did thank you so much
for watching and as always see you SMS
oh never mind you can keep the water
alright let's get some good shots oh my
lord
holy [ __ ] bikini split oh my lord oh oh
holy holy holy holy holy moly